a major deadline today for thousands of
local casino employees both mgm and
westgate implemented their own vaccine
mandate requiring workers to show proof
of vaccination so we begin here at four
o'clock with joe mohler he's live near
mgm with a look at the plans joe
both of these companies have their own
mandates mgm's applies to all their area
resort properties and to all salaried as
well as new employees hired after august
30th
mandatory testing is still in effect for
pre-existing hourly employees who don't
want to get vaccinated they plan to
release vaccine numbers next week today
mgm held a job there at the boulevard
mall one woman looking for a job says
she doesn't mind the new mandate tell
him i was vaccinated and
they asked if i had a health card it's
only requirement i think it's just a
safer way to go the westgate policy
applies to all non-union workers unless
they provide proof of medical or
religious exemption westgate officials
tell 8 news now the vast majority of
those employees plan to be vaccinated by
this weekend
back out here live the culinary union
supports measures put in place to
protect workers the representative tells
me they are actively negotiating with
gaming companies to have agreements that
reflect their health and safety goals
reporting live near the strip john
muller live local now